[Música]
y en directo a vamos hasta perú allí
saludamos a nuestro corresponsal
francisco zacarías para discutir sobre
dos situaciones que sacó de nuevamente
al presidente pedro castillo por un lado
un nuevo intento por inhabilitar lo en
medio de acusaciones de traición a la
patria y por otro la investigación por
corrupción en contra de jennifer paredes
cuñada del mandatario y quien es buscada
por la fiscalía francisco buenas noches
la fiscalía como lo mencionamos intenta
detener en el palacio de gobierno a la
cuñada del presidente pedro castillo
previamente captura a otras tres
personas investigadas por tráfico de
influencias cómo afecta esto al
mandatario
buenas noches una corte emitió una orden
de detención contra cuatro personas
entre las que se encuentra jennifer
paredes como usted lo ha dicho ella es
cuñada del presidente de pedro castillo
por delitos contra la tranquilidad
pública organización criminal y lavado
de activos es por eso que desde las
cinco de la tarde un equipo de fiscales
y la policía se encuentra al interior
del palacio del gobierno tratando de
capturar a la cuñada del mandatario
peruano la tesis de la fiscalía es que
los comprendidos en el petitorio de
detención no solamente van a brindar
información que permita esclarecer las
denuncias también aportarán pruebas
contundentes al ministerio público en
las investigaciones por presunta
corrupción que existen contra pedro
casillas
y por otro lado en que se respalda el
informe parlamentario que recomienda
someter a juicio político al presidente
pedro castillo por supuesta traición a
la patria además de su inhabilitación
por cinco años
el informe señala que el presidente
pedro casi o habría violado cinco
artículos de la constitución política
peruana en especial el artículo 54 que
establece que el territorio peruano es
inalienable e inviolable se argumenta
que pedro castillo habría excedido su
uso de poder como presidente para
ofrecer una salida al mar a bolivia el
reporte del
parlamento afirma que el presidente
pedro castillo sería presunto autor del
delito de traición a la patria que es
sancionado por el artículo 325 del
código penal peruano